with DW here in the US and today we are
interviewing Cass muda he is a professor
at the school of public and
international Affairs at the University
of Georgia and also at the center for
research on extremism he is an expert on
political extremism and populism in the
wake of the shooting in Buffalo where
the black community in particular was
targeted and 10 people were killed I
wanted to ask him about far-right Terror
attacks the great replacement Theory and
what it tells us about political
extremism
Cass thanks so much for joining us today
the great replacement theory that a
group of powerful Elites are controlling
the US government the media and that
they're trying to replace white
Americans with people of color where did
this idea come from well in its most uh
modern uh variety it originated with a
French author called javasfai who wrote
a book to Kemp of the Saints in 1973 and
since then it has been around in Far
Right circles pretty prominent actually
since at least the 1980s and more
recently another French author kamu
wrote about the great replacement and
that is what you now often see referred
but broader this idea of an elite trying
to replace the original population with
immigrants who are more docile so that
they can control them has been around
for for a very long time I would say the
mid 19th country here in the U.S
who are these Elites that are being
referred to
well that is um often implicit but
initially it was in many theories very
explicit was the Jews later it was
either
um big Capital which quite often is also
the Juice or left-wing parties and you
see it particularly since the 1980s
1990s more referring to left-wing groups
and now the newest iteration which
brings everything back is George Soros
um the Hungarian Jewish financier and so
he combines both the left and the Jewish
and big Capital part okay and you've
made the point that we should not be
amplifying the manifesto that the
shooter in Buffalo allegedly left behind
but I do want to ask you about the fact
that in his Manifesto he refers to the
Christchurch mosque shootings in 2019 as
the Tipping Point and we saw a similar
language around the utoya shooting in
Norway why do you think we're seeing a
growing number of attacks fueled by this
Theory well first of all we there is
social media spreads everything much
faster but the media in general is often
very obsessed with these kind of what
they call Lone wolves
um who Who attack things particularly if
they're far right we give them a lot of
attention they mention their name
endlessly and so they become within the
movement these people become kind of
like Heroes with regard to the great
replacement Theory it has really
mainstream and you see that for example
here in the US with Tucker Carlson of
course on Fox news but also high ranking
uh Republicans like um Elise stefanik
but even like yesterday in the new
speech as as the new uh for his new term
as Hungarian prime minister Victor Orban
replay referred literally to the great
replacement Theory so this is no longer
a theory from some marginal all groups
on the far right this is within the
broader mainstream right now I'll come
back to the European angle in a second
but just to follow up on this great
replacement Theory DW spoke to members
of the black community in Buffalo who
said you call this replacement for us
this is just plain racism
um would you agree with that now
obviously underlying the great
replacement theory is it a racist idea
that non-white people are inferior right
that's why they're being brought in
because they're mordoso so this is not
just a replacement of white Americans by
white Norwegians or something this is by
non-whites and they do that because the
assumption is that these people are
inferior so it's absolutely old school
races if we come back to the European
aspect now this is something that we've
seen in Germany certainly among the far
right there this use of the great
replacement Theory but how How Deeply
seated is it in Europe as well
part of the research the far right in
the late 80s early 90s it was already a
prominent Theory then in parties like
the center party from National all kinds
of parties like this is really one of
the key ideas and there it was almost
always linked to the left this is what
the left and for the far right of course
the left includes everything up until
like the Christian democrats this is
what they do now again it has become
more prominent in part because the far
right has become more prominent so now
you see it with Eric zenua for example
in France and you see it even with prime
ministers like Victor Orban can you help
us pick up
plus stream and how
like the shooter in Buffalo can become
radicalized I mean what are the factors
leading to that well these are two
different
um processes so the mainstreaming is
something that happens largely outside
of the far right itself it is it is
other actors both in the media in
politics in um in cultural sectors who
are picking up on these ideas and and a
lot of this goes back to 9 11 pretty
much which shifted the whole debate from
socio-economic to social cultural and
shifted our debate about
multiculturalism and immigration
becoming much more negative to the
extent that pretty much there was a
consensus in 2015-16
um in in a lot of circles that
immigration is a threat to national
identity and National Security Now if
you're there then it is not a big step
to get into the great replacement Theory
now the process of radicalization is at
a much more individual level
and to be honest that is quite difficult
to generalize upon this particular
shooter
um has his own Narrative of what has
happened and I think we should be very
careful about
um taking that uh for granted he kind of
argues that he radicalized during the
pandemic and and online in general
that's highly unlikely it's not as if he
was
totally Pro Multicultural then there was
a lockdown and he got sucked in he
probably had these ideas already and he
probably had them from mainstream Media
or family or whatever other his cheers
her but we do know that the pandemic has
radicalized certain people because she
get lonely you get isolated and you live
online in a bubble that you narrow down
more and more okay so that's a
contributing factor how much do you
think on a larger scale in the U.S and
also in Europe does this have to do with
demographics the fact that on a whole in
the country like the us is going to at
some point in the near future see white
Americans actually be in the minority
well so this is a major difference
between the US and Western Europe right
I mean the US is far more diverse and
actually less racial terms than any
country even France or or Britain
since at least the 1980s but probably
even before that there has been growing
anxiety within white particularly right
wing and also Christian circles that the
U.S is becoming a majority minority
country and already for decades they
point to the year 2050 where that would
happen now that was all even heightened
by the fact that Barack Obama became the
first black president and that was kind
of like a sign for many uh who who were
vulnerable for this and who who worry
about whites no longer being majority
it's like look they already have the
President right and so Barack Obama
as president created an even more
feverish uh debate about this uh
demographic change and that has been
heightened then of course by the whole
trumpification of the Republican party
if we look at where things stand now um
the Biden Administration has said that
the greatest threat to American Security
is violent extremism fueled by white
supremacy and I read that you said that
you don't believe that the far-right
threat is primarily a security threat
and what did you mean by that so I don't
think that that the biggest threat is a
violent domestic history is fueled by uh
white supremacy I do believe that the
biggest domestic violence uh threat is
from white supremacy but in the end
individual shooters or even smaller
groups of terrorists are not threatening
U.S society let alone the U.S political
system
what is threatening the system is white
supremacy that has pretty much captured
the the Republican Party
the larger conservative movement
including Fox News like we now have
Across the Nation like a republican uh
legislators who are undermining the
democratic system who are pretty much
whipping up fear and anger over a sudden
border and a crisis at a southern border
which which doesn't exist they they act
as if there's an invasion of gang
members that are going to kill and rape
and plunder the United States right that
that is my point my my point is that the
main threat is within the political
system what I'm saying is they're
they're not legally responsible
obviously they have a moral responsible
uh responsibility but they're not
legally responsible but my broader point
is that the Buffalo terrorist is not the
main threat the main threat is
Republicans undermining the democratic
system and using the great replacement
Theory to kind of rally up their baits
what can be done to counter that now to
be almost very little because for me
most measures be they preventative or
repressive you actually need support
from the Republicans either in
Washington or to implement them at the
state level or in law enforcement
agencies now a recent study shows that
about half of Republican supporters
believe in the great replacement Theory
they're not going to implement these
policies that you're talking about so
sure it is easy to have even more
repression to Target these individuals
like the shooter in Buffalo and some
others but the broader problem of the
great replacement Theory like
undermining like pretty much the whole
idea of of America as a multi-racial
country that you cannot attack when it
is believed by so many people many of
them of course work in legislatures law
enforcement intelligence agencies Etc
even if social media platforms were to
be better regulated to curb unfiltered
speech hate speech social media are only
a very small part of this as long as it
is belted by Tucker Carlson on Fox News
and repeated through Breitbart and all
these other things then whatever Twitter
does is simply not that important and
just to add to that what about
internationally since this is a theory
and a type of radicalization that we're
seeing internationally as well well many
countries are are nowhere near the the
problematic level as the U.S and so
while they have a reasonably strong
far-right party although in Germany for
example it's not even that strong the
vast majority are still people who
believe in Liberal democracy and who
don't believe in a great placement fear
first and foremost they have to call it
out more one of the most striking things
was when Orba made this speech various
International media didn't even mention
his reference to the great replacement
Theory
um
both what's left on the line
and Sean Michelle from the European
Union like congratulated Victor Orban on
a new on a new term as Victor oriban was
blaming Europe of the EU of committing
like a suicide of the white people like
you can't do those things you have to
you have to choose liberal democracy
that's a good note to end on Professor
thank you so much for joining us thank
you for having me